on this what happened ally
morning okay well this happened about 24
hours ago in abu dhabi as you say a
number of drones caused explosions just
outside abu dhabi international airport
now we don't know whether the airport
was in fact the target
and those attacks missed or whether they
did hit their target in this industrial
zone
and therefore we don't know the
significance of that target because the
emiratis haven't told us yet
nevertheless uh the consequence was a
number of fatalities three people were
killed
two of them indian one of them pakistani
and six more were injured not the first
time i should say that the houthis have
launched attacks on the uae of this kind
they also quite regularly i say
regularly you know it's not uncommon
that they launch tax as well on saudi
territory including the capital riyadh
the reason being because uh saudi arabia
in particular but the uae as well have
been involved in the conflict uh in
yemen against the iranian-backed houthis
now
the uae has actually tried to extract
itself from that conflict over the last
couple of years and barring uh some sort
of military and small military
involvement to defend key positions they
are not so involved in the conflict
anymore but the houthis are trying to
force them out of yemen
completely the retaliation came
overnight when the uae
launched airstrikes against uh key
houthi targets in the yemeni capital
sana
killing 14 people that's the latest
death toll including one former military
figure according to the houthis but as
we know it
no key
houthi
figures have been killed in those
retaliatory airstrikes
okay ali thanks